Breaking Bad is one of the best shows in
TV history and after five seasons it all
led to an ending that people still talk
about today but if you need a helping
hand to understand that final episode
well then let's cook creator Vince
Gilligan had one of the best
high-concept hooks for Breaking Bad that
any show has ever had as Gilligan put it
this is a story about a man who
transforms himself from mr. chips into
Scarface the appeal of Breaking Bad is
pretty simple because it asks a question
we've all probably wondered at least
once how far would a regular person a
mr. chips type go if they knew they were
dying and had to provide for their
family with that theme in mind it's easy
to see how Breaking Bad is about the
American Dream the idea that if you do
good work then the people in charge will
see your value and reward you for your
skills of course most people would
prefer their paychecks come from
legitimate bosses and not various
criminal drug lords in the crystal-meth
trade not so for Walter White's after
all the longer he stays in the game the
higher he Rises but the higher he Rises
it gets harder and harder for him to
argue that he's just leaving a nest egg
for his family and he transforms from a
sympathetic and unlikely antihero into a
full-fledged villain say my name
Heisenberg so we've spent a lot of time
talking about waltz but what does the
actual ending of Breaking Bad mean well
first we need to specify which ending
we're talking about each of the final
three episodes
Ozymandias Granite State and Felina can
function as a kind of ending for the
show in the case of Ozymandias it's a
poetic circular ending my name is on the
Andes king of kings
Walt betrays Jesse completely by giving
his former partner up to the white
supremacists he's been working with
worse still he admits to Jesse that he
watched Jane die and did nothing
I watched her overdose and choke to
death I could have saved her I didn't
but even before handing Jesse over to
the Nazis Walt is indirectly responsible
for getting Hank his DEA brother-in-law
killed and then Walt has to watch his
uncle Jack and his white supremacist
gang take away all his earnings except
one single barrel of cash Walt then has
to roll the barrel back toward
civilization passing by the pair of
pants he lost in the very first episode
when he tries to convince his family to
flee with him his wife and son attack
him and Walt kidnaps his infant daughter
it's all of Walt's lies laid bare he
chose an empire over his family and like
the Shelly poem the episode is named
after says no Empire lasts forever
Walt has the money to flee into a kind
of witness protection program for
criminals but he's giving up the family
that he pretended to do so much for if
Ozymandias is the realistic end to
Walt's journey then Granite State is a
fitting punishment for the former meth
kingpin Walt ends up in a remote cabin
where his only company ed the disappear
comes by just once a month to drop off
supplies even in the kind of purgatory
that Walt lives in he's still not free
of his cancer and he's constantly
waiting for Edie to return with
chemotherapy drugs it's a fitting
punishment for a man who pretended to do
everything he did out of loyalty and
family obligations Walt is so lonely
that he ends up paying it thousands of
dollars just for an extra hour of his
time he's alive and rich but all alone
much like the characters of a different
AMC show Walt is basically the Walking
Dead the only thing that brings him out
of his mountain retreat is the
possibility of passing on his ill-gotten
gains to his family
Walt literally tries to buy his way back
into his son's affections and of course
it doesn't work however he's given one
last goal when he sees his former
colleagues Gretchen and Elliott on
television downplaying Walt's
contributions to their company gray
matter technologies it's reasonable that
they would after all it's not exactly
good for a company's stock to have a
co-founder become a murderous drug
kingpin Walt's unsurprisingly does not
see their side of things instead he
things are disrespecting him by not
giving him credits Felina the finale
episode of Breaking Bad is basically a
victory lap for waltz he gets to
accomplish everything that he left his
mountain retreat to do he threatens
Gretchen and Elliott into giving all of
his money to his family under the guise
of a charitable donation Gretchen would
you mind I don't want to lose any end of
the furniture all right he kills all the
white supremacists that stole his blue
meth recipe Walt frees Jesse from
slavery and he even gets a kind of
closure with Skyler and his infant
daughter plus he poisons Lydia with a
whole lot of ricin and he successfully
invades to police all the way to the end
even when he appears to die it's on his
own terms he's not writing of cancer but
dying in the arms of his true love the
chemistry lab that produces his blue
meth Walt is infamous which as we know
from the three amigos is when you're
more than famous combine all of these
facts and it's hard to deny that this is
Walter's perfect inevitable ending
Felina might be Walt's fantasy but it's
everyone else's nightmare
throughout the episode Walt is a
monstrous presence he moves through
scenes like a horror movie slasher when
he talks to Skyler he appears like a
ghost the scene is even blocked like a
jump-scare
when he brags to Lydia about how he
poisoned her drink it's a moment that
wouldn't be out of place in a final
destination movie Walt gets his victory
lap in the final episode but it's only
because he's chasing his enemies around
the track even when Jesse escapes the
white supremacist compound fully free of
Walt and his vindictive torturers he
lets out a guttural scream straight from
the Texas Chainsaw Massacre if there's
anyone in the show that knows what kind
of monster Walt was it's Jesse when he
drives out of the show it's as
viscerally satisfying as seeing the
final girl in a horror movie survived
the killer
waltz starts breaking bed by telling his
family that he loves them and that
everything he did was for their sake he
ends the show hobbling out to the mess
shed to be with what he truly loves his
work his legacy it's clear that he was
never really mr. chips whatever falling
out happened between him and his
partners before the show started was a
symptom of something deeper Walt's
cancer was just an excuse for him to be
the power-hungry villain he'd always
wanted to be as Vince Gilligan once put
it we always say in the writers room if
Walter White has a true superpower it's
not his knowledge of chemistry or his
intellect it's his ability to lie to
himself he is the world's greatest liar
Walt lied to himself for so long that he
believed his own lies for most of the
show he lied to the audience to how much
he wants to believe that Walt was a good
man is dependent on how much you want to
believe his lies was he good man who
broke bad or was he always a twisted
monster who finally got the excuse to
behave like Scarface check out one of
our newest videos right here Plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]